he is actually doing really great i mean
look you know
everybody's up against their own demons
sometimes it's anxiety and depression
sometimes it's substance abuse kristen
bell is standing by her man
i just want everything to be working the
actress's hubby dak
shepard recently opened up about his
relapse with prescription medication
following 16 years of sobriety and on
wednesday
kristen talked about his journey on the
ellen degeneres show
the thing i love most about dax is a
that he was able to
tell me and tell us and say
we need a different plan right like we
have a plan if he gets it if he has to
take medication for any reason i have to
administer it but he was like
so we need a stronger plan i was
faltering
and i have to do some sort of emotional
work to figure out
why i wanted to use again not only did
the good play star praise dax for coming
to her for help following his relapse
she says she has full confidence in him
one of the main reasons i love him is
that he's
also addicted to growth he's addicted to
evolving and he was like i don't want to
risk this family and i did
so let's put you know new things in
place to make sure it doesn't happen
again and he's
you know we're going back to therapy and
i just i
i love that he's addicted to growth and
i will continue to stand by him because
he's
very very worth it the 45 year old actor
opened up about his relapse in september
on his armchair expert podcast i guess
the other reservation i had about coming
clean publicly is like
ugh kristen doesn't deserve for the next
six months for every
interview she does to be oh dax relapse
i know
his relapse came after he sustained
several injuries this year doing extreme
sports
and began taking prescription pain
medication
dax revealed he started to significantly
up his dosage
which led him to start lying and i'm
lying to other people
yep and i know i have to quit
but my tolerance is going up so quickly
that i'm now in a
situation where i'm taking you know 8
30s a day and i know that's an
amount that's going to result in a
pretty bad withdrawal
and i start getting really scared and
i'm starting to feel
really lonely and i just have this
enormous secret
one thing's for sure dax and kristen are
open and honest
and always keep it real we have gotten
on each other's
last nerve this last couple weeks
it's we're doing much better now because
we're laughing about it but we were not
laughing about it for the first couple
days
and that's the hard spot back in april
et caught up with the frozen star and
she admitted it took a minute for them
to adjust to life in quarantine
amid the coronavirus pandemic i love
spending time with him and he loves
spending time with me but i think what
is different about this quarantine time
is you have so much more time to think
about the other person and their actions
and sort of
um replay what they said or or or
attach a meaning to something that they
did and like
that i could do without nobody really
needs time for that that's
that's useless and she noted that the
key to a happy marriage under lockdown
is finding a little space for alone time
you got to in america you've got to
you